let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about graphing using
cartesian coordinates
cartesian that's an n cartesian
coordinates
and that sounds like a very fancy
concept but all it is is a way of
specifying or showing locations in two
dimensions when i me when i say two
dimensions i just mean something like
this screen that you're looking at on
the surface of the screen or the
computer screen that you're looking at
you can either go up and down so that's
one dimension or you could go
left or right that would be another
dimension so that's why we say two
dimensions if we talked about three
dimensions you could do either of these
and you could either pop out of the
screen or go into the screen but you
can't do that so this is just a
two-dimensional world this green right
here two dimensional
now cartesian coordinates you can
actually use for an any dimensional
world and i won't go into that just yet
but we'll apply it to two dimensions
because that's the first place that most
people really get serious exposure to
graphing so if we're dealing with a
two-dimensional world let's say we have
some reference point
we have some reference point here we
call that reference point the origin
we call that the origin
if we want to specify some other point
on that origin in cartesian coordinates
essentially we just say how far to the
right or left are we of that origin so
in this case how far to the right of
that origin and we also say how far
above or below that origin so we this
would be how far above the origin in
this case and so
the first coordinate is how far to the
right of the origin and then the second
coordinate is how far above the origin
i'll put them in quotation marks because
this isn't the most the most matty way
to talk about it but this is essentially
what cartesian coordinates tell us so
let me graph some because i think it's
always useful to see some examples so
let me define my origin
and these reference lines that i'm
drawing here not that very neatly we
call these
the axes or if we if we want to just let
me just call this the horizontal axis
right now and or we could also call it
the x-axis and i'll talk i'll tell you
in a second why it's called that let's
say we have a vertical axis like this
let's say my vertical axis i'll do it
like that in pink
so let's say that is my vertical axis
right there
so this is horizontal
horizontal and then i have my vertical
which is essentially how far up and down
and then i have my origin and we specify
the origin
its coordinate is okay how far is that
to the left or the right of the origin
well it's
it's zero to the right of the origin
it's right on the origin and how far
above or below the origin is it well
it's only zero above or below the origin
so its coordinate is zero zero so the
coordinate of the origin
is just going to be zero zero now let's
say i have some point here
that looks like
this
we do it in a darker color let's say i
have some point like that what is that
point's coordinate going to be
well it's let me draw a line like this
its first coordinate is how far to the
right that's what i said before so it's
let's see it's 1
2
three to the right we could mark these
one two three to the right so it's three
to the right and then how far above or
up from the origin is it well it's one
two three
so it's three three that is this point's
cartesian coordinate now what if i had a
point over here do it in gray
say i had a point over here
this seems a little bit trickier so how
far to the right of the origin is this
well we aren't to the right we're to the
left of the origin we're to the left of
the origin and so the convention is we
could say it's an it's a negative number
to the right of the origin so we're one
two three four five six this minus six
so we are minus six
to the right of the origin we can just
say that we're six units to the left
that a negative number here means that
we're moving to the left in our
cartesian coordinates at least the way
i've drawn them and then we are going
down
one two three and the convention for
down is we say use a negative number so
we are minus three
so we were six to the left or we could
say we're minus six to the right and
we're three down or we could say we're
minus 3 up either way i think you get
the idea minus 6 minus 3
is that point right there let's do one
more point
let's say i have
that point right there we do it in this
color
what's its coordinate what's 2 to the
left it's 2 to the left so it's going to
be minus 2 right
1 2 and then it's 1 2 3 4 up so it's
going to be -2 4. if you compare it to
these axes right here you would have the
point on this axis plus 4 and over here
on this axis you would have the point -2
it's that straightforward now let's go
the other way let's actually graph some
points
let's say i want to graph
let's say that i want to graph the
points
i don't know let me pick let's say i
want to graph the point minus 1 2
i want to graph the point
i want to graph the point 7
4
i want to graph the point
3
minus 5
and i want to graph the point
minus
4
minus 4. so where are these points going
to be well the first thing i have to do
i have to specify my origin
let me do that so let me draw some axes
here
so that is one axis that's my horizontal
axis
axis
this is my vertical axis
and then i could draw them better than
that let me see if i can draw a little
bit straighter
that's a little bit straighter
and of course right at the center the
coordinate for the center of the origin
is just 0 0
so it's just 0 0 that's your origin
right there let's graph the rest of
these points and i'll make one one
little side note here i said in the
beginning that this horizontal axis this
horizontal axis right here is often
called the x-axis
and this vertical axis right here
this vertical axis right here is often
called the y-axis and this is just a
convention because when you write these
coordinates people tend to call how far
you're going in the horizontal direction
the x-coordinate
x coordinate
and they the second number how far you
go in the up or down direction is your y
coordinate
y coordinate
this is just a convention that you
normally say that your coordinates are x
comma y how far you're moving to the
left or the right of the origin how far
are you moving above or below the origin
so given that let's graph these guys
so that first one i added in pink so
i'll graph and pick minus 1 2
for 1 to the left that's what the minus
tells us we're moving to the left so
we're going to go one to the left right
there so our x coordinate is minus 1 and
then we're going to go positive 2 that's
our y coordinate so 1 2
positive 2 right there so it's that
point right there is minus 1 2
that's that point right there now the
next one was 7 4 so we're going to go 7
to the right we have a positive number
so we're going to go to the right
1 two three four five six seven its x
coordinate is seven its y coordinate is
positive four so we're gonna go four up
one two three four
so it's that right there so that is
seven four now we have this character up
here
three minus five
so we're going to go three to the right
remember the first coordinate is in the
horizontal direction so we go one two
three and the second coordinate is
our up or down it's negative so we go
down so we're gonna go down five so
one two three four five so this is minus
five this is three so we go three to the
right down five we end up right over
there
three
minus five and then finally i have this
point here minus four minus four so this
tells me four to the left
of my origin so one
two three four that's an x coordinate of
minus four and this tells me four down
so one two three four this is a y
coordinate of minus four so it's four to
the left four down gets me right there
minus four minus 4. now given what we've
just learned right here let's see if we
can use this in the adaptive program
i've written in if you don't know what
the adaptive program is that's fine
it'll still be instructive i think for
being able to graph this so the level 1
graphing module on the adapter program
it gives you problems like this and it
asks you
which of the coordinates which of the
coordinate pairs is not is not graphed
so you look at these coordinates and you
see if they are graphed if one of these
isn't graphed then that's your answer
so let's look at this i have minus 6
minus 6 so that's 6 to the left
right there and then that's 6 down
right there so that's that point and if
you're watching this in hd you will see
that this is definitely graphed minus
six
minus six just like that let me do it in
a darker and a darker color
in a darker color
what about the point one zero
well that's one to the right and zero up
and if you see if you're watching it in
hd which hopefully you are you'll see a
point there so it is definitely graphed
so it is one zero so both of these are
definitely graphed so those are not our
choices what about the next one minus
eight minus nine
so that we go to the left one two three
four five six seven eight
that's our x coordinate and then minus
nine is our y coordinate so we go down
nine so we're gonna go down one two
three four
5 6 7 8 9. there's nothing there it has
not been graphed there's nothing here
there's nothing there it should have
been it has not been graphed so that is
our answer that one has not been graphed
the other ones have been 3 minus one is
three to the right minus one down that's
been graphed three six three to the
right six up that has also been graphed
so everything else has been graphed and
actually this year we didn't even see a
choice for this but this has also been
graphed
minus 1 all the way to 5 so this is the
point minus 1
5. not one of the choices but it's also
graphed there let's do this one more
time
let's do it one more time okay
so the point minus six minus one
six to the left gets us there that's
minus six if you can read that and then
minus one one down gets us to that point
it has been graphed
four minus six four to the right one two
three four to the right and then six
down gets us to this point right here it
has also been graphed so neither of
these are the correct answer minus nine
four
we go minus nine one two three four five
six seven eight nine that's nine to the
left that's what the negative tells us
then we go four up one two three four it
has been graphed so that's not our
answer
four two
we go four to the right
4 to the right and then we go up 1
2
4 4 3 has been graphed but 4 2 there's
nothing there
there's nothing there
so it has not been graphed so 4 2
is our answer just to make sure let's
see if one five has been graphed one to
the right positive one says to the right
five tells us five up
it has indeed been graphed so that's not
our choice so the answer was four two
hopefully this gives you a good at least
basis to go on and start graphing things
with reckless abandon